哈囉 我是夏森林
聽天分想集團遊批本定定裝
他們是我從上百平比裝裡面選出來的精品
而且我都是自用了非常非常久的時間了
沒有一次的文化動動
不管是動動還是只提玫瑰對照膚質選
不覺得你們又完之後都不會想要再換
首先是這款本上
我的超級正愛我從2016年用到現在
我2016年那兒的臉上都超級嚴重
我當時用了他很多人都覺得
我的皮膚很好
那兒我是一個超級大量的臉
就是用什麼底妝都溫鬥
但是用他不溫
他是五右配方裡面80%
以上都是養腹成分
在我手裡面有幾十上百平分別的情況下
我還能把他用空三四萬
就真的太好用了
粉質比很多有色面刷還要吸你
所以隨便抹一抹
他就會融進你的皮膚裡面
把毛孔修飾得特別好
他很輕寶非哪怕你多圖幾層
他都不會後久
帶妝一天下來你的臉
只會出友
但是不會脫妝搬火幅粉
到了晚上
那個皮膚就像開了美眼影一樣
看起來細膩光滑
現在的臉很貴氣
像是每個月發五六位數保養的
貴膚奶油筋
遮瑕力並不高
但是完全沒有妝感
多多劑你們就拿他和遮瑕去滴
會讓你們妝感看起來清雲很多
現在才是這隻有色面刷
好用愛用
所以我一定要給你們多嘴氣劇
我是從去年年底
用到他結合我就是
一發不可收視
因為用他實在是太方便了
你圖他一隻就相當於是用了
物理防禦價格理價底妝
平時我都是換膚之後
直接用他然後再用麵粉餅
定妝就能出門了
妝笑完全不輸給這些貴服底妝
非常地輕隱
但是用能把氣色沉痛得很好
我也試過把他當作一款
較色隔離
後續點一些比較輕透的底妝
說來妝感也是很好看
很服天很細膩的
而且這款他是做完了光片下午之後也可以用的
接下來是這個
一隻非常平價的遮瑕
他是專門用來遮鬥鬥和鬥硬的
我用下來覺得他比很多樣子的遮瑕還要好用
裡面是加了水洋酸和藍漫夜提取物
一邊幫我們遮瑕
一邊還能幫我們吹鼠鬥
讓鬥鬥鬥趕快平調
致地是做的
用熱淡時就8.0的推開之後
粉質非常細膩跟皮膚融合得很好
沒有任何編輯的感
就把你那個鬥
你那個瑕疵跟遮住了
而且他只要
即時快起來有時刻
用來做就想的話
可以用汗汗汗長一段時間
這個真的是非常推薦的鬥鬥的時間
接下來是這一款粉底液
這個老粉應該都熟悉的把握
22年的時候就跟大家分享過當時
我有做過對練測品
我覺得他的致地比22年的時候要更輕隱了一些
比22年的時候還要好
有其實22年當時我用他就覺得很好用了
跟有色面霜還滿像的
就是很好圖的那種
妝男很像那種日系的貴婦底妝
就是妝感不強
遮瑕力也不是很強
但是皮膚顯得就是又量又透
不是那種一件魔皮的粉底
反而會保留肌膚的這種瘟力
很有呼吸感
遮瑕力也不是很高
所以需要遮瑕的話
只有搭配這個遮瑕起來起來
想要那種很自然
還有光澤
皮膚像雙平奶一樣
不讓量的太坦的
這就可以選他
最後是一個鬥肌
零肌致皮都能用的一個底妝組合
是這個品牌的
他們是專門做成境財妝的
用的是礦物粉底
所以問題肌膚用他們
就不用擔心說
很加重皮膚的膚膽
我之前是用過很多礦物的妝的
但是礦物的妝都有一個痛病
就是粉質會做的
相對來說
粗糙很多
就你上臉會感覺分乾很重
不信你
但是他們家的就不會
這個粉底液他的妝感
剛上臉的時候
非常的漂亮
是那種非常輕透的塑研裸肌感
但是遮瑕力又很強
臉上的一些小瑕絲
基本上七七八八都能夠遮得住
他的遮瑕力
我今天分享所有底妝裡面
最強的一塊
但是他把遮瑕的那種
厚重的妝感
平衡的非常好
就是遮得有的老
但是妝感有很輕
可以把我們臉上的毛
恐嚇下刺多弱化很多
而且如果你的皮膚沒有
側了別的油的話
你上完他
超甚至都不需要定妝了
因為他上完之後是乾爽的
但是呢
他有一個缺點
就是說他的帶妝時間長了之後
臉上會容易出現白質
所以如果是追求長時間帶妝的話
最好水深要帶個
補妝的東西稍微補一下
然後這一塊粉並也是超厲害的
上臉之後
一秒柔焦甲光
相當是個皮膚一件抹皮了
但是粉質就做得很細密
不快相帶的面具一樣
而且如果我之前用的是那種
很有光澤感的底妝的話
他會保留一些
我臉上那種光澤感
我特別喜歡他的設計
他的粉並下面有一個
專門方粉膚的位
這樣就不會把我們的粉膚弄髮了
這一點真的是做得非常好